hey guys this is the Reuben report I am
Dave Rubin and I've got Ben mankiewicz
Jimmy Dore with me
I should tell you right up front this is
the first panel ever that is being
brought back by popular demand you the
people demanded that I bring back these
two together and that's what we did do
you have any thoughts on that before we
begin perhaps they're fans of the the
Jimmy Dore show I think that's what it
was how many subscribers therefore the
Jimmy Dore show we're up to 125,000 all
right there you go very good all right
nice let's talk about Robin Williams so
obviously that's the the big news this
week apparently he commits suicide 63
years old you've heard all about it
obviously so let's just watch them I
know
size can be daunting but don't be afraid
I love you LSD I'll be talking to every
blade of grass like sorry sorry sir so
walk into a major league baseball
stadium like Shh in your face camel cake
in your rear cover you're lying crying
spying point also big you Luke rude rude
back a period food dude now you asked me
if I've been practicing medicine well if
this means opening your door to those in
need those in pain
caring for them listening to them
applying a cold cloth until a fever
breaks if this is practicing medicine if
this is treating a patient and I am
guilty as charged sir all right a true
legend obviously and just insane talent
I mean everything he did was good so I
thought having you two on for this would
be perfect because I got the movie guy
and the comedy guy so let's start with
the movie guy I'm not even gonna give
you a question just give me something
just agree with you right off the bat
please challenge the host everything he
did wasn't good in fact many of them
were very very bad
and you want to save this for the end
you want to start their band no because
the the the testament to his strength as
a performer is that he had he I think he
could have made a thousand bad movies
and everyone still loved Robin Williams
it didn't matter is his thing and his
thing was varied you know he could be
very somber and very dark and then
everybody knows how sort of exuberant
and sort of you know scandalously over
the top he could be it didn't matter
we still loved Robin Williams even if
you walked out of a movie and thought
that was a horrible way so what were
some of the bad ones because when I was
looking through the list everyone I kept
looking I was like love that love that
love that business great centennial man
I get others Day and Father's Day with
Billy Crystal that was the one that
really sucked because the museum like
the later ones you know the first one
was okay but I mean these are kids
movies they were they weren't serious
but I liked the first night at the
Museum fine yeah but I mean there's a
there's a pretty good list of 10 or 12
movies plus it you know canceled
television show the critics didn't were
like I never saw it so I think it's a
testament to how great a performer he
was that he could perform in so many
different ways live in front of a crowd
as a stand-up in a theater on television
or in movies and the quality overall
quality of the work was sometimes
questionable but but his work was never
really questionable and whatever this
sort of feeling that we had to care
about him
persevered no matter the strength of the
material yeah before we get to the dark
comedian secret that kind of thing do
you think there's ever gonna be a
performer we don't have those guys
anymore the band's talking about the
guys that can do stand-up that can act
in movies you know he was just in a
sitcom it was cancelled but we really
don't have those guys ain't not
everybody Epsons gone I don't really
think I think you talk about you you
love Robin Williams even in he's in a
bad movie I mean that's the same like
with Ishtar I thought he was great in
that I thought here that people didn't
like that movie Beverly Hills Cop was
son of of his best work though the thing
was weird when he was in matrix I was
like this is gonna be weird cuz I'm
gonna be laughs big but it still it
worked it worked he played kind of
dumber than he is and the thing that
killed me like his you to mention his
television
I was like just not and I was going nuts
when they cancelled Boston Legal I'm
like that is the best goddamn I mean
ever wouldn't emmys but they didn't care
about the quality right so then they
gave him some shitty show on CBS so
whatever but anyways I loved all that
stuff you know I watch him and anything
and I didn't think you know people gave
him [ __ ] well he shouldn't be Batman but
I thought you did a great job he was
fantastic that's why I loved him he was
a chameleon right he could do anything
yeah he's a very very much like Jack
Nicholson in that way I'm very shocked
how this segment is started we went
immediately to his bad movies and now to
the lesser-known cameos that I had in
those rows no but all right Tech Poets
Society was a big movie that influenced
my life yeah for real like so when I saw
it and I had only heard you know he was
course a hero to me when he was Mork &
Mindy and then I saw Dead Poets Society
and it woke up something in me like Oh
everything's [ __ ] and that's when I
kind of realized it in the world and
nothing matters and tried to have some
honey drip off your tongue while you're
still alive
yeah so and I don't mean that in a
filthy way it sounded kind of filled
yeah well I do go to honey pots in
Marino and that's a fun anyway let me
tell one amusing story about Dead Poets
Society that relates not to Robin
Williams but to Joe Biden okay so at TCM
we do this thing in 2004 where we talked
to politicians about the movies that
influenced their lives and we get an
incredible group because we get John
Edwards John McCain Joe Biden like three
guys who made some news in the years
that followed right and then Orrin Hatch
[ __ ] so you had two Democrats two posts
oh and talked Biden picked Dead Poets
Society right but only because it was
shot in Delaware I was like the first
movie shot Tyler so in talking to him
about it I would say you know what the
message of the movie that you know that
sort of to challenge authority and
question things and believe in yourself
and stand up for what you believe in and
he'd be like yeah that was great
I just remember the scene where they're
running over the hills and that was in
mind that was not
my house up every question he would
answer with something about Delaware
Biden yeah I mean that really is so
Biden all right Jimmy explain the the
dark mind of the comedian because that's
what everybody's talking about these
people make everybody laugh that's what
we do but secretly we're all depressed
well you'll see yes well would like
every what people go well doesn't a lot
of comedy come from dark yes well that's
what you need comedy for you don't need
comedy to lighten the load of your day
at Disneyland
you need comedy to lighten the load of
the [ __ ] horrible [ __ ] in your life
right you need to talk about he talks
about drug addiction and stuff you know
P that's why people can't comedians
constantly talk about their marriages or
their relationships or their work or
whatever it's things that frustrate us
that we need comedic relief from so of
course he was depressed and it seems
like you know like the more depressed
you are except for Jerry Seinfeld it
seemed like the more messed up you are
the better your art is that seems to be
always what it is right because you feel
a need to connect with people more you
need to express yourself more because
you have angst and so he had them so
when people that's kind of Bobby when
they go oh well he was the you know he's
a clown but he's got to have a dark side
everybody has a dark side we just have
also a talent for comedy
everybody's messed up there are 30,000
or 39,000 suicides a year in America so
it's not they're not all comedians right
they're not all kimete exactly only well
I always think it's funny when they I
think they just juxtapose it because
it's like you how can you be dark and
then also make people like God well it's
such a simplistic way of looking you
says it like Jerry Seinfeld says he has
a you know I remember he was talking
with Garry Shandling Gere saying so do
you think that it's because we're
screwed up and and she says no we have a
type of talent they have a talent for
comedy how about I'm a regular person
and I have a talent for this so I just
think that you know I think comedians on
a lot of ways used to call me to get
attention I'm sure that's what he did
right like when I was you know when I
met Robin he was very he he didn't
really get going until there were a
couple of people in the room yeah I mean
and even and that's what I noticed
anyway firsthand yeah but I I think that
that bothers me when people say
comedians are depressed or they're
darker they won't know we have a talent
we learned how to get attention being
funny which to me is the best gift you
can give somebody if you tell someone
something that makes them laugh you've
just lighten their day you've made them
connected to the moment you're live
in the present so now that spiritual to
me comedy is my spirituality as an
auntie and I are the greatest people
alive yeah as a non comedian I'd like to
share my thoughts on that because I
think you're bye-bye by echoing Jerry
Seinfeld's Point which is a good point
that I'm just talented and I'm a regular
person it ignores the fact that there is
something particularly special about the
talent that you have and it's possible
we don't really know that that talent
comes from something else that there is
some other part of you and doesn't mean
that all of you were depressed it might
mean that there's a 28% chance that some
of your or more are darker and I just
think that that's possible it doesn't
change what's true about what he says it
does seem based on 100% anecdotal
evidence that the times that that we
that the regular folks among us run into
comedians in places where they're not on
you often think not that that guy wasn't
funny but that like way that guy was
like it was that guy seemed or that guy
that guy seemed kind of bummed out like
not what you'd expect but but that also
may just be our inability to process a
difference between obviously you're on
stage and you wouldn't meet Laurence
Olivier and be like hey that guy wasn't
that guy acting when we were having a
whiskey at a cocktail party medians are
supposed to be themselves and actors are
supposed to be someone else that's right
that's right that's right
but what comedians are a sliver of who
they are and then you amp that up so the
best part of who you are the most
likeable giant charming part of who you
are you'd amp that up on stage so that's
not your whole you can't shoot me I
don't want to see you go out there with
a belt wait quick before we gotta wrap
this one up do you think part of this
though is also that Hollywood kind of I
know that's a broad statement but
Hollywood kind of doesn't know how to
deal with people with that level of
talent like they can sort of deal with
people that have a certain amount of
talent a lot of talent often but he was
really off the charts and maybe that
sort of fed into whatever was going on a
lot of really talented people they don't
quite know what to do with I think I
think that there's some truth to it I
certainly feel misunderstood
we're talking mostly about people with a
lot of talent I mean I hear you but even
a little yeah even a little battle don't
get it all right bring us home like you
thought I was serious about the ishtar
thing that's what I'm talking about this
is the kind of [ __ ] I run into every
goddamn day
the thing about Robin Williams was is
that and and we don't know because none
of us knew him well Jimmy met him but
none of us knew him well yeah so like he
seemed unlike some comedians even some
very funny comedians to be incredibly
authentic as funny as Jerry Seinfeld is
I don't feel like I have any insight
into Jerry Seinfeld at all
Robin Williams appeared to make you feel
like you sort of knew Robin Williams uh
therefore it seems incongruous
to have a guy this sad look can I read
one quote and then we'll go so this is
what he told Marc Maron in 2010 talking
about the downside of his career it's
trying to fill a hole and it's fear he
told Marion you're going what am i doing
in my career you bottomed out people say
you have an Academy Award the Academy
Award lasted about a week and then one
week later people are going hey Mork ah
so really yeah I mean that's why I van
Gogh cut is your office oh that's that's
the so that's the thing right so people
think well he had everything well that's
the mistake we make in American culture
and a lot of cultures is that we think
fulfillment is on the other side of
achievement right and then I don't know
if you if when you achieve a couple of
big things in your life you go hey
that's bunch of [ __ ] I feel exactly
the same and I feel a little [ __ ]
cheated actually I've arrived but I
don't feel any different
I'm exactly myself give me a belt in a
[ __ ] closet door because I want to
kill myself it's almost like you need
the hole to have talent you need that
pain to have talent but then you got to
sort of heal that thing to really count
itself O'Neill the talent all right
let's move on so Isis so you know last
week we did a video and I said
everyone's talking about Isis now we
were a day or two ahead of the thing
they are releasing these insane videos
of beheadings and massacres and just
shooting people in the streets and all
this terrible stuff and we showed one of
them last week
and now we actually found a worse one so
I'm just warning you this is beyond
graphic and
horrible so you are warned okay so that
was Isis beheading a Syrian soldier in
Syria not in Iraq they are in Iraq and
Syria and I think it's important to show
this stuff because the mainstream media
isn't showing it partly just because
it's so graphic but also this is
spreading this is getting worse every
day I feel like we don't even know how
to talk about this because it's that
horrific and we've never dealt with
anything of that level people say really
bad things about Isis but they did
return that severed head to its rightful
body at the end of that video so you
know just a great sandal make sure we
put it all in context yeah I think it's
important to show it to I don't I think
we should be careful a little bit not I
think you should show it and we should
talk about it but but I mean Iraq and
Syria for the last few years I mean it's
not the first beheading I don't know
whether these guys are doing it a ton
more than was happening in Iraq when you
know more than a hundred thousand
civilians were killed during the war
right we do it yeah rules if you shoot
you know ten thousand people some they
somehow think that's not that bad but if
we see a hundred people decapitated then
it's worse but I guess it's the optics
of it well I think that guy was already
dead I'm pretty sure so I don't think it
bothered him that much yeah so yeah it
gets back to this thing of war like
what's cool what's not cool like somehow
that's worse then you they already
killed them so I don't I understand you
supposed to have reverence for a body
and all that stuff which I don't know
how much I believe in and it's in and
for real right and because it's jus it
just makes people crazier right all we
have to protect this sacred body the
the guys that already it doesn't really
matter and III you know yeah they
wouldn't be heading people they used to
have fur guillotines and for civil
societies so this is not that to me it's
like it's gruesome to look at but you
know it's not any more gruesome than the
rest of the war they have 40 thousand
people on the top of a mountain that
they're trying to kill that they're not
they don't even have shoes or water
they're dying from first right so right
now we are down doing some strikes and
we apparently drop some food and someone
yes so uh you know I I'm getting that
that thing that people had when during
the Syria thing you know some people
wanted weather we gotta go back I'm
getting that right even though I'm
totally against that stuff yeah like I
had a I was walking my dog today I was
like I would like to go shoot some Isis
guys so that so that's the thing about
this well for what one they stopped
doing the guillotine in part because was
too hard to cut somebody's head off even
with the guillotine which that video
shows it's not easy which is why they
ultimately stopped just from a manpower
point of view it's just a lot of work uh
for very little reward but the reward
that they have now is terror yeah it
strikes terror into people and of course
what this builds the danger of what this
builds and what they are hope you know
they what they would like to accomplish
I suspect if they're this sophisticated
about it is that you know John Kerry and
the Foreign Minister of Australia get on
television and they talk about the
picture of the boy with the sever well
let's show that right now so like in
that picture does nothing like
everybody's grotesque group unless you
see the real picture this means nothing
right so this is the seven-year-old son
of a guy named Khalid Sharif who was a
convicted Australian terrorist who left
Australia to go fight for Isis and he
brought his kid so yeah we I do the only
image we could find was with try I tried
to find the real one and I couldn't do
it turns out that that guy's dad is
schizophrenic case yeah
and he's been in hospitals and he's been
and and somebody they treated him and
they're like any secured he's a he's a
he's a comedian yeah he's just the
comedian issues you know issues yeah so
what what what worries me and as it
worries me but I'm certain it will
happen is that you get John Kerry in the
Foreign Minister of Australia talking
about how hideous this is
everybody's talking about it is this is
at some point someone some Western
country will capture some Isis guys
right and we will think these are the
guys we sauce on this guy's head off
right in this kit made his kid hold a
severed head John Kerry was revolted by
right well we're not gonna want to give
that guy a trial we're not gonna care
how long we lock that guy up without
giving him a trial and throw them away
in a Cell or execute him and never let
him see a judge you know this week Ramzi
bin al-shibh one of the orchestrators of
the 9/11 attack which we who we caught
in 2002 he just had his trial separated
from the other guys it's 2014 these guys
haven't gone in front of a judge yet for
their formal trial and the prosecuting
saying it's outrageous how can you
separate this trial when it seems like
there's real evidence that the torture
that we did to Ben I'll she has made him
insane and he's not competent to assist
in his own defense we don't care we
don't care because they killed 3,000
people and the system that we had and
the structure of Justice is supposed to
apply to everyone but these guys are
gonna make us once again shrug our
shoulders and abandon any sort of rule
of law because we're gonna feel like
these guys when they sawed off that
Syrian soldiers head they lost the right
to be treated civilly and the war
machine will continue are we really
dealing with saying that we've never
done with in that regard like they want
us to play on our worst parts of
ourselves that seems obvious they want
war
you know you mean it's like with with
Hamas and they want dead civilians on
both sides so then they force Israel to
shoot and that Israel does something
they don't want to do and then you just
get more dead people so are we and we're
really in like a culture war right now
right across the world I would disagree
with that framing but I I don't remember
what your question was let's move on to
so Isis again is there basically that's
about Isis right so this just goes again
the hubris of American foreign policy to
think that somehow we're gonna go fix
the Middle East right so we're gonna go
and we're going to bring democracy to
the people of Iraq with their
purple figures they [ __ ] voted so
like that was some kind of a thing so
well everybody said what happened
exactly happened there's a power vacuum
and the worst of the worst so we made
the system twenty five billion dollars
twenty five billion dollars we spent
training the Iraqi army 700 of those
Isis guys chased 35,000 Iraqi army guys
with this drop the uniforms 11 by the
way this is now using our stop you think
they're using our uh artillery in right
because they just stole it John McCain
would probably say we gotta give the
arms to someone else that somebody in a
cabbage Democrats and Republicans
telling Barack Obama that we made a huge
mistake by that by not giving arms to
Syrian moderates as if we could figure
out figure out who they were and that
now Isis is fill the power vacuum that
we abandoned I mean we need the only
legitimate criticism that you can give
to the administration in Syria to me is
well we did nothing in this happened but
you cannot extrapolate that this
happened because we did not like what it
did something it might have been worse
lately or or more likely nothing but it
would have it would have very lot more
us arms there right and we'd be
essentially in the same situation but
that we could have prevented it by
funding these guys I think is is silly
and we what we and the fact of the
matter is we absolutely can't possibly
know right and we fund guys and then we
fund the guys that come after them and
when the Syria thing was happening I
remember me and you were the two that
were completely against the war I mean
think about it we they wanted to bomb
Assad well then that would have just now
strength into Isis so everything we do
is kind of backwards so it goes to my
last question on this was this sort of
the perfect storm of we had the war that
was made up the original the Iraq war
that george w bush it's obviously his in
Cheney's fault
but then Obama was sort of the perfect
president to now screw it up even
further by completely getting us out you
know me like everyone wanted out but by
just we had a bad president that got us
in and then this guy that just felt like
well it's not ours to take care of
anymore so it was sort of perfect storm
of well this is what's gonna happen I
don't know III don't I don't agree with
that I don't I think one of the good
things that he's not as you get us out I
mean I don't know what the alternative I
know the alternative is either and so at
some point you have to leave I mean I
don't know what's long enough yeah eight
years strikes me is probably long enough
three years longer the world worked
strikes me is long enough uh and I don't
know what we could have done and what
you think if we'd spent another seven
billion dollars and trained those guys
for another year they'd have been better
yeah I think they didn't want to fight
so we just don't know what we're doing
that sort of no doubt about that David I
don't understand why like oh so we're a
Saudi Arabia you know why don't why
aren't they what don't they have a
problem with Isis or are they cool with
Isis right god they got a problem with
Isis is a threat Saudi Arabia is part of
the California bout Egypt you know what
about like why don't we have to do and
we have to do what Saudi Arabia there's
other countries Jordan which is what
sama bin Laden said about when we went
into Kuwait to the United States went
into the Kuwait he's like you know why
didn't we take care of this why we got
to ask the infidels to come over and
take care of this and that's what bad
exactly why didn't Saudi Arabia take
care of Kuwait why didn't think [ __ ]
do that why did we have to go so that's
what I don't get like what are the other
Arab oil rich countries doing with all
their money and weaponry right so let's
see what happens one thing that Isis has
done well is they're paying guys who are
paying poor young men to fight are they
capable of governing
I doubt it no I doubt it no you know and
and we still don't know how many guys
there are how many are we talking about
so what was the UN to like worst why
don't they why don't wasn't there a
force that can go in and save these
people why I don't think we have a force
anyone you know I know that but I don't
think it exists anymore I think it's
training I know the u.s. does something
or nobody does anything and I don't know
that either one's any better but yes as
Isis is rampaging across Iraq and Syria
the emir of mosul had some interesting
things to say about their grand plans
this is nothing we're just at the
beginning up until now we've used just a
small part of the forces that we have at
our disposition you cannot imagine how
strong we really are we have immense
power you will be amazed you won't be
able to defeat us and he goes on we've
never feared the Americans not even in
the past when they were in a weaker
position why on earth do you think we
would fear them now we've beaten them
before and we'll beat them again Allah
curse the Americans and their allies
they will come to a very bed and so I
think a lot of this is probably just
posturing and all this stuff but do we
have to take any of this seriously now
is this part of that you know
uh Ralph Harris the famous atheist says
that you know it's a it takes religion
to make men do things that are horrible
like this right to cut someone's head
off to kill 40,000 people so would you
say this is a part as its religion or is
this what what would use I would say
that this is again one part of the bad
parts of religion right yeah I would
agree I mean I think it's probably 75%
religion 25% of our policies that
propped up awful people to repress their
own people and this is what you get
yeah I don't know the only issue to me
only relevant question is what we do now
and you know if these guys you know we
saw their that was we we know they know
I'm just gonna leave there like that
words gonna know that words gonna call
it sexy attack and I some reasons not a
yeah oh yeah that's right baby
uh so like if they're 700 of these guys
are 1,700 or 2700 we should bomb the
living [ __ ] out uh especially if they're
in the open uh you know we're not is
this is not gossip these are this is not
a densely populated city where kids and
women and children live in innocent men
so strike while you can because maybe
that will do the trick if they're
stronger than that then we're gonna have
to deal with them uh I don't think any
of us want to go fight a war against
them uh and send in American troops and
send in 75,000 American troops to fight
these guys there uh because they'll win
in the long run they'll win abilities if
they live they live there we want to go
home so uh you hope that you can build a
political diplomatic coalition of Arab
neighbors and friends and allies uh who
will help you to politically isolate
these guys I don't know if that's
possible but that you civil wars raging
that's very hard to do right so do you
that just doesn't exist though right it
doesn't seem to be right unless you
unless you really have oil companies
wanting it to happen remember when
George Bush went crazy trying to get the
Coalition of the Willing hey we've got
36 countries with a but that wasn't a
real coalition so we need to put
together a real coalition like a real un
again I mean that's what really needs to
happen you need to have a bunch of
countries and they're fighting against
them but this is the world against them
yeah it seems to me that that's gone
like this thing with the CDs on the
mountain yeah if there were everyone
knew there were 40,000 people sitting up
there starving to death
they were surrounding the mountain Isis
and everyone was saying what are we
gonna do what are we gonna do and it's
like well obviously only using the
United States was gonna do it so this is
like our curse right this is now our
curse well I wouldn't Saudi Arabia do
something why wouldn't another country I
just don't think they I think every
right to the US will come in and clean
up the mess but it's becoming a problem
on the streets of Europe we've got an
interesting image out of Holland these
are Isis flags being flown in Holland so
what are these this is happening now
there'd been Isis flags in London
they've been in Paris like what is
happening here and you know Europe has
this major immigration problem
especially France because they've led in
a lot of people that didn't get
integrated in society properly what are
you supposed to do I mean we don't have
it here in America I saw there was one
in New Jersey actually that right there
was one guy we remember after 9/11 the
football player from the Phoenix
Cardinals have forget his name now
Tillman Pat Tillman is so up you get so
worked up and he went any volunteers you
want to go kill some al-qaeda from
America yeah I literally that's how I
feel about these Isis guys and they
really haven't even done anything to us
yet I got I swear I'm walking my dog
like a fighter god I would join you over
there start shooting some em efforts so
what'd he make know of what are the
Europeans must do this stuff it seems
like it's growing there now they're not
they're not beheading it but the flags
that like who who in their right mind
lives in a western country and is
somehow backing that I get you know more
about me because I'm not getting it well
clearly you have to be a serious
practicing Muslim to begin with right
so only say and and to some extent
somewhat fundamentalist the difference
that the thing that we can't do is look
at people in Holland with a flag who are
saying look at the guys who have been in
their mind perhaps pushed around forever
Yeah right and now are standing up and
our men are winning we never win and
here we are in this stage winning
because the West has already left and
what we can't do is presume that these
guys hold the flags
well we have to be wary of it but we can
presume these guys all the flags are
ready to take up arms in anyway most of
these people gonna go back home and cook
dinner and
for their jobs in the next morning but
they like the fact that they're winning
free speech and everything with you know
to me it's like the same thing if you
carry around a KKK yeah or not or
swastika it's like this is only about
hate and killing it's the most heinous
thing we are terrorism we're the
embodiment of it we're trying to scare
the [ __ ] out of the world so it's like
you want to scare the [ __ ] out of me
well how about I try to scare the [ __ ]
out of you back because we can well I
think partly they're empowered because I
think they think that you're just gonna
do know that so that but it's gonna come
down to what do they do if they are able
to succeed because at some point the
only way they're gonna keep anyone in
any of those places happy and by the way
they're gonna kill though mostly who
they kill of course are Muslims like at
some point that's gonna bother that's
what I think about everyone everyone
else right so at but again it depends on
whether you're Sunni or Shia but that
but at some point they're gonna have to
open school and they're gonna have to
run water to people and they're gonna
have to provide basic services yes and
they have to prove that they can do that
right now they've just hired a bunch of
thugs to go cut people's heads off i I
don't know that that like that that
video is gonna scare us of the severed
head I suspect that that as we see more
that it will also scare plenty of people
it's so easy transition from head sever
into roads and transportation so Hillary
Clinton is in some hot water with
President Obama she's been making the
rounds you know she's in the media every
freaking day and she basically said that
Obama should have armed the Syrian
rebels which we've already been talking
about and why do we think that would
have worked I do not know but the Daily
Beast had an interesting piece on this
according to one of the lawmakers
senator bob Corker asked the president a
long question that included sharp
criticism of President Obama's handling
of a number of foreign policy issues
including Syria Isis Russia and Ukraine
Obama answered corker at length then the
president defended his administration's
actions on Syria saying that the notion
that many have put forth regarding
arming the rebels in Syria would have
to better outcomes in Syria was
horseshit holy cow the president kitty
said horseshit so this seems like it's a
kind of direct attack on Hillary why is
it a direct attack on Hillary because
she because she give the dirt but her
quote about arming the rebels was pretty
tepid like this is a first of all this
is gonna be nothing in regard to Hillary
and Obama yeah it is not in Hillary's
interest to be seen as an Obama Lackey
at all she has to stay close enough to
him so she doesn't alienate mainstream
Democrats she won't do that but
obviously showing some independence from
the administration that is relatively
unpopular not as unpopular as people
would like to have you believe is a
useful political tool but she didn't say
anything like Obama made a mistake
she said that she argued knowing how
difficult to arm a certain select group
of Syrian moderates and that it might
have helped and now the reason this is a
stories was the president said the word
portion which is horseshit like they may
have said it like I hope he said it
doubly fumin moment that he had the
White House has confirmed the exchange
with Senator corker of Tennessee they
have not confirmed the use of the
expletive [ __ ] you who cares whether use
that or [ __ ] in a private meeting oh
great now Ben mankiewicz said [ __ ] you
about horseshit but we've got the quote
from Hillary Obama's failure to help
build up a credible fighting force of
the people who were originators of the
protest against Assad there were
Islamists there were secularists they
were everything in the middle the
failure to do that left a big vacuum
which the jihadists have now filled so
that I had read oh yeah well you're
retracting your attack that that's a
straw I still think it's anything and I
still think the political part of this
stands that that's a strong that's
that's a strong anti Obama quote but
that said it's that there are plenty of
of Democrats in the House and the Senate
who believe that exact same thing who
were at that big lunch of lawmakers with
the president to discuss foreign policy
right before Congress when I recess
Hillary now is counter among them there
is obviously a significant disagreement
about what we should have done in Syria
I don't think it's that big a deal that
it suggests that there's a huge fight
yeah all right well you hit most of the
media
as part of this just that Obama is
basically in lame duck territory at this
point so Hillary by hitting him no no
see her back right I agree there's no
sweat off her back I think Tuesday I
just want to make two points you know
Hillary's saying that's completely
politics and she's a war hawk and she's
a corporatist and she's our Liberal
candidate what do you make of her moving
to the right now because she lost into
this because she went to the right well
but that's what she did in 2000 he was
to the right right Obama so lost so why
do it now doesn't this seem a little
early actually you know it's just just
the way the gears work man she's been
doing she's been to the right ever since
1992 so if she doesn't know how to do
anything else
I mean she's sitting on the boards of
Walmart she's deregulating [ __ ] she's
pushing forward a corporatist health
care reform she's she's deep regulating
Wall Street she is exactly the opposite
of FDR's either the eggs opposite she
might be good on women's issues and
that's what we're left with we're left
and the margins lilly Ledbetter and
abortion but not the core thing that
makes people radical that makes Clyde
Bundy and all those [ __ ] want to
take up arms against the government it's
because we're being screwed over the
biggest ass reaming in the history of
this country is happening right now from
the military-industrial complex
and Wall Street and they somehow got us
[ __ ] angry at each other because
there's no good jobs 50% of the people
in America earn less than $30,000 that's
workers so there's a big problem that
creates unrest and that's what's gonna
radicalize America and she's part of it
and the reason she goes oh the problem
here is Barack Obama and he didn't arm
the frickin rebel the problem is there
was a goddamn drought in Syria that's
what this all got started because there
was a drought and people didn't have
jobs their farms failed they went into
the cities there was no food and water
in the cities and the you know and the
world did not respond people and they
asked for help in Syria and they did not
respond sorry filibustered up but I
think that what's interesting about
Jimmy said and I agree with I think a
hundred percent of it we just not agree
with yourself a second ago give me a
second yet come around uh if Hillary had
shown
backbone that she is once again not
showing in 2004-2005 and come out
against the Iraq war any time before it
was like the meter went yes
okay now it's safe to come out against
it she'd be president United States yes
so no doubt lesson lesson not learned no
and if Barack Obama would say horseshit
more often he would be a more effective
president they have a real moment
instead of always constantly choosing
his words with a million odds and
qualifiers in between that's why people
like George Bush because he said stuff
like horseshit and he did any talk like
a regular person so people thought it
was authentic and people think Barack
Obama isn't authentic because he's not
authentic so real quick is the horseshit
moment is that just sort of like Obama's
just I feel like he's just kind of done
now like he's ready to move to Palm
Springs I mean if he would have been
done six years ago he could have got a
lot more [ __ ] done that's the truth
there you go all right let's keep it
political this one is I literally cannot
believe this story the White House is
reversing a ban on lobbyists we talk
about money in politics here every week
this is pretty much the root of all
problems nobody is debating that and the
White House is on the wrong side of it
let's look at a little info this is from
Politico the new rule affects a policy
implemented in June 2010 as part of
Barack Obama's ethics package but keeps
some of the ban in place lobbyists will
be allowed to serve only in commissions
and boards in a representative capacity
so long as they're acting on behalf of a
corporation trade association or
industry group and not as private
citizens or representatives of the
government that seems that it's it can
please go I think the opposite of what
you're supposed to do it's like well if
you want to come here in size innocent
okay but if you're gonna be representing
some big behemoths money maker who's
gonna undermine democracy no oh no it's
the opposite if you're if you're
speaking for someone who wants to
undermine the democratic process with
money come on in if you're regular
citizen go pound sands why the the
problem with this and and the defense of
the Obama administration ears that
they're reacting to a court ruling that
they lost they were on the right side of
this it was not the strongest lobbyist
band in the first place but now even the
moderate strength of it was undermined
it was undermined by the appellate court
so this goes to the point that the
Wolfpack is involved and yes
unless you change the Constitution is
really hard to do anything right and you
read the quotes in this story and it's
all about like the most powerful people
in the world saying finally we get a
seat at the table
they are literally saying you only get a
seat at the table if you have money if
you are a regular citizen
I just don't so what's the
administration why do this wait they law
reporter than why push this even further
I mean they're just responding to that
they're largely responding to the defeat
of a court case here's where I don't
look I don't think they're like I can't
believe about this court case is
devastating they lost the court case
what the guess the opposite of what
George Bush would have done he would
have just said well we don't agree with
that court's decision we're gonna keep
doing it this way that's exactly what
Barack Obama should have said and who's
good who's what's he gonna do what's he
gonna do to put in the public opinion
he's not he's gonna say hey you know I'm
fighting against lobbyists here and
that's a winner for him but again it's
he's that's not who he is he's one of
them people always say why is he doing
he's goddamn one of them so is that the
thing then that we have gotten so we
never talk we talk about it here but the
media literally never talks about
campaign finance anymore so is that why
for him it's not a winning it's not a
winning issue not that he needs to win
again but it's not even an issue for him
to go out on cuz just nobody gives up
well like for instance abortion the
Republicans know it's never gonna be
overturned but they'd [ __ ] bring it
up every five seconds right because it's
a big winner for them politically yeah
this actually could have traction in
legislatures and get overturned as an
amendment or yeah and it's a political
winner and he still doesn't bring it up
there's one it both ways with everything
I remember during the campaign he kept
saying how they're not going to use
super PACs they're not going to use
super PACs and then and then Romney
started using super PACs so then Obama
was like well we have no choice because
we have to do it so he kind of does want
it both ways cuz he knew that that was
ultimately gonna happen right the
Republicans were gonna do it then
everyone would be like well you gotta do
it too because this sucks so he you
gotta watch both yeah I mean I would
have done the same thing in that case I
I wouldn't fail we're at the game but if
the game it's important that somebody
says that the beat you know it's
important at least that we talk about
this is the first time we really could
in this last election talk about super
PACs so at least some
but he says each time this is terrible
maybe at some point they'll go away it
doesn't seem like we're headed in that
direction right now yeah National Retail
Federation store magazine came out with
a list of the top 10 retailers these are
the top 10 retailers that are growing
right now we've got a list so this is
interesting stuff here so amazon.com
number 1 Sherwin Williams 2 chick-fil-a
Family Dollar Stores Apple Tractor
Supply Company
Whole Foods AT&T Wireless Signet
jewelers Starbucks leave it up for just
one second here so there's this is kind
of all over the place and that's what I
thought was interesting so you've got
something like Whole Foods at number 7
that's really high-end stuff and
extremely expensive and then if you look
at number 4 you've also got Family
Dollar Stores number 5 like I mean you
got and then number 5 you got the
extremely unless they mean actually and
their people are moving apples
yeah what's missing yeah Walmart is
missing from their target in terms of
growth that's why so this is these are
the ones that are growing okay that's
why I thought this was particularly
interesting so you've got companies that
are extremely expensive and things that
are really cheap and doesn't that pretty
much sum up everything in America right
because there's some disparity right
it's the Gilded Age again that's
happening people don't realize it I was
at a party the other night and I was
trying to explain to a guy that the
middle class has been decimated and he
smirked that means like they've been
decimated hey do you have any kids you
try to send them to college it's your
house underwater is did you lose your
retirement when the stock market crashed
did you know that 50% of all wage
earners in America make less than
$30,000 do you know that 64% of
Americans have [ __ ] zero savings for
retirement yes the middle class has been
decimated and that's you know what so I
don't know maybe I'm reading too much
into that that's why but you that's
exactly your point that if they're going
after high-end people and low-end people
right it's a its burgers and yachts
I guess Sherwin Williams they're there
for I mean I look I think that that's
true I don't know that that list
represents that first of all I didn't
realize
the paint age like Cheryl Williams is
exploding what do they go that that for
crying out loud Bette what are they
doing the Benjamin Moore isn't kidding
oh my god you pulled that one out
hurricanes they sold a lot more stuff
right that's what I think that's a I
think can we put the list up ago there's
like some of it is like you know a
everyone is becoming wireless even poor
people right nobody doesn't have a cell
phone
not nobody but almost everybody and I
thought like tractor supply that
suggests that I don't know of growth in
farms Starbucks is high-end coffee but
like did you I don't know chick-fil-a is
cheap yeah and the paint store might be
cheap and every 18 t Wireless I suspect
that that's perhaps because the base of
wireless customers that's growing might
well be lower end people well that's
what it I think that is what it is
because they have their subsidiaries
like cricket which work off the AT&T
networks but they're much much cheaper
they throttle your daddle and all that
what do you guys make a chick-fil-a I
guess that whole anti-gay thing didn't
really hurt them on know that seems to
help it helps a lot helps out a lot
right and I you know as much as I like
you but in general I don't like gays
anymore and I might like him again in
the in the future gays depending on how
hungry I am yeah that's true yeah so we
were driving to Rehoboth Beach Delaware
which is a very friendly [ __ ] for
pointing at booking on raggert I'm sorry
very gay friendly Joe Biden's been there
Jill Biden's been there right it was two
miles from his house so we drive up and
and we're hungry and we pull into a
outlet mall and the only place that you
could eat in the outlet mall was a
portable chick-fil-a I mean check filet
wait what does that mean um like a like
a chick-fil-a truck oh jeez well they
exist and so a chicken truck and we're
hungry and it's the middle of Delaware
which means go take 10 or 15 minutes to
get to the end of Delaware and but we
were hungry and that's where we were
worth my 90 year old father and I hadn't
eaten chick-fil-a in two years it's a
tough moment so you ate it I ate your
food and did you realize as you're
eating it you were
were kicking me in the nuts I did I did
and but the thing of it is I ate it and
I really I felt terrible I was like I
went two years I go to Atlanta every six
weeks I don't eat it you know it's
impossible nothing in Atlanta but I
think there's an exception for a mobile
truck I think there's a definite caveat
I would rather eat a [ __ ] sandwich then
go and get a chick-fil-a I'll tell you
that that can be arranged too that's
what I'm saying I've had a few all right
robots might soon be taking your order
at McDonald's that's right take a look
at this image that was posted on reddit
by snail mail 0:07 he spotted a robotic
McDonald's machine at a restaurant near
Romeoville Illinois and this is where
all of McDonald's latest technology gets
tested first and you know we see all
these things I thought this was
interesting because we don't really see
these at fast-food places or at
restaurants but we do see these like at
CBS and that kind of thing where you
check out yourselves but McDonald's is
not the only food chain that's hoping to
replace human employees Panera Bread is
going to replace their cashiers all of
their cashiers with robots I guess I
like all those things rope I like Panera
by 2016 you like Panera Bread I do uh
what do you guys make this because there
is an economic part of this which goes
the story we just did that you know
these companies keep wanting to maximize
profits and Republicans I suppose would
argue if you keep making minimum wage go
higher well then we're gonna fire all
these people so that we can hire robots
so where do you fall as no there's no
number as no you can't make minimum wage
low enough for those guys not to want to
fire people res no not what if there is
no no so uh I would I just read a story
yesterday that you know we're we have
we're having this recovery is great the
jobs are coming back right but they are
coming back they're not nearly the
quality of jobs that were lost so if
this now starts to happen in that in
that people coming back to finding work
at jobs like that then what's the next
job what job do people take when they
come back we still have to repair
I'm pretty sure they're not gonna be as
many robot mechanics as there are
cashiers at mcdonnell's about robot
robot masseuse right Susan
sexpot we've talked a lot you get the
food when you punch it in there that is
a failure that is not gonna work you
don't think that's gonna work that it's
not there's no idea it's just not me it
doesn't work when there's a person that
well it's like oh and what is the
problem with Kesha oh I hate cashiers I
ain't talking to a person what I want to
order that's not it so no it Mattel's
anything anything that's moderately
cheap at so many places you know you no
longer signing your credit card yeah
even if you using your debit card or
credit card whatever it is yeah either
through its 573 you know who cares then
you look at your statement at the end of
the month and you're like Jesus I went
to wedding do you think it's gonna work
yeah here's what I would do
yeah it might work just like the airline
you think the airlines right they all
got deregulated so they all race to the
bottom with the cheapest fares and it's
only like now like if it took for 20
years or 30 years for virgin to go hey
we're gonna give you a little bit better
experience it might cost a little bit
more so that's what I think like fast
food you would think yeah fast food
chains burger we're gonna have we have
real people here you know you would also
think that a shoe company would go I
have a billboard up that says we make
our shoes here in America by adults you
think that would that would help you
sell right we think they would do all
that chick but they don't right maybe
they won't do it and we'll just get
[ __ ] over because corporations don't
really provide us choice what we did a
story a couple weeks ago about how
Macduff's is putting their employees
through online college and I was asking
the guests if they if that would make
you more inclined to go to Starbucks
because even if you have to pay a little
bit more you know they're doing
something socially yes responded yeah
yes the next the next [ __ ] in a mask
that throws a trash can through
Starbucks gonna have to deal with this
with like like and by this I mean I'm
gonna shake my bar but like Starbucks
they're good and enough with that they
came in and they ruined all the local
coffee there were none local garbage
I couldn't get coffee and I hope you
don't feel by the way Ben has the old
school in New York City I ordered the
coffee cup I have so much disposable
income you order that I ordered these
cups so I could fill my coffee at home
with these yeah yeah that's forgetting
the economic part though do you think
that's just something about losing a
little bit of the human interaction not
not that the people are so great at that
look you go to in-and-out they're nice
they're smiley and friendly I'm always
amazed I don't know yeah I think they're
hopped up on drugs I don't know what's
going on stone but in McDonald they're
never friendly or happy to be there or
whatever or not I don't blame them they
work in a pretty crappy job for a low
amount of money and we've all done that
and the uniform doesn't help in a little
hat okay fine
but do you think we lose something by
eventually if everything is just robots
and touchscreens I mean we're doing this
all day on our phone anyway now we go to
get food and we're still doing this all
day then yes we do definitely lose
something we're becoming isolated from
me not only from society but from each
other you know Noam Chomsky talks about
this this is what they want they want
you to be isolated they want you to
think that your thoughts are only your
own and nobody else is thinking them and
all that stuff
this is horrible right yes I think this
is bad I really hope maybe this will
push if they all go robots
you know Wendy's and McDonald's and
Burger King if they all go robots
maybe this will maybe there will be
local burger stands again maybe this
will make that happen you know I've if
Starbucks went all robots maybe there
would be local coffee shops that would
open up I don't think people like buying
food from robots you know this has been
since the internet age came and I
remember conversation with one of my
friends at like age 22 23 you know you
can call and you get your groceries
delivered you have to go the grocery
store and I was like I want to go to the
grocery store and I didn't have a mobile
phone then I was like I want to go the
grocery store I want and like you know
whatever I overreact that it's nice to
be able to call and get your food
delivered if you don't want to but
obviously as we see just you know slowly
20 years 25 30 years you start losing
connections with people and that that
matters people work from home to lose
connections to people in the grocery
store so they started instituting a few
years ago the node there's no checker
there's no cashier you just go do it
yourself which I hate that it's like hey
we'll get hey we figured out a way to
cut someone's job out to people there's
no bagger there's no thing this is gonna
be a headache for you and a pain in the
ass but it makes us more money so I just
steal it yeah
I steal whatever I whatever I got card
machine whatever you get Hannah and
that's that's my way of pushing back all
right final thought I asked this almost
every week one way or another what year
do you predict the robots will take over
about 2012 they've already taken over I
was just gonna say the same they are
they took over a long time ago Wow
oh that's deep that's deep all right you
mean I'm talking robots like you know
David Gregory he's getting replaced by a
new by another Rover robot with a goatee
isn't that nice so just real quick
that's a better robot that's a better
robot it's a slightly better
I think it's significantly better but
that speaks more to David to the
incompetent nature Dave Greg David
Gregory you know I learned something by
watching the dog whisperer that it
doesn't matter what's inside the dog
because he's gonna make that dog over
ever he wants so the same thing with
Chuck Todd yeah he works for a defense
contractor how many checks you take him
a defense contractor before you'd stop
calling yourself a journalist or a giant
telecommunication general electrical
ones 49% of Comcast yes okay we're just
gonna keep doing this cuz this is what
we do when we're not on camera anyway so
follow Ben and Jimmy on Twitter it's
right down below get Jimmy's book we'll
put a link to it in the description and
we will do this again next week thanks
guys thank you Dave thank you Dave
you're welcome guys